[Music]
but of course we've got to begin with
the breaking news it happened overnight
on the unprecedented there's that word
again fbi search of donald trump's
florida home the former president says
he will not oppose the justice
department's request to reveal its
search warrant agent search mar-a-lago
on monday they were looking for
classified documents including now this
is according to the washington post that
some of them involve nuclear weapons
attorney general merrick garland asked a
judge yesterday to release that warrant
now that is a highly highly unusual move
when no charges have been filed as jeff
piguets reports he said the public
deserves to know what's going on in this
case
i personally approved the decision to
seek a search warrant in this matter on
thursday attorney general merrick
garland announced the justice department
filed a motion to make public the
warrant used to search the florida
residence of the former president
according to the washington post the fbi
agents searching mar-a-lago monday were
in part looking for documents related to
nuclear weapons the search warrant was
authorized by a federal court
upon the required finding of probable
cause the unprecedented search of the
former president's home as reported by
the post reveals deep concerns about the
sensitive information that the
government believes could have been at
mr trump's mar-a-lago home and the
potential danger of it falling into the
wrong hands mr trump supporters and gop
leaders had been calling for the
attorney general to explain the doj's
actions they've taken this unprecedented
step weaponizing federal agencies to go
after political opponents and then not
even explaining to the american people
what they were doing the warrant and
property receipt if unsealed would
reveal what the fbi was looking for in
the list of items taken
in a statement the former president
insisted that his attorneys and
representatives were cooperating fully
the fbi search in mar-a-lago has sparked
a wave of violent threats against the
justice department garland defended fbi
agents and prosecutors every day
they protect the american people from
violent crime
terrorism and other threats to their
safety
while safeguarding our civil rights i
will not stand by silently when their
integrity is unfairly attacked
the former president firing back at the
attorney general this morning with yet
another attack on law enforcement this
time via truth social
saying nuclear weapons issue is a hoax
just like russia russia russia was a
hoax a former president obviously
referring to the russia investigation
during his term in office something that
at that time he called
illegitimate well that's what he's doing
now with this investigation that the
department of justice considers
quite
important and it is unprecedented in so
many ways tony
jeff thank you very much